mr speaker with permission i will make a
statement on our progress against
omicron and the review of our plan b
measures within hours of learning from
scientists in south africa about the
emergence of a new covid variant last
november this government acted
introducing balanced and proportionate
restrictions at our borders to slow the
seeding of omicron in our country
as we learned more about this highly
transmissible new variant we implemented
the plan b measures we had prepared
precisely in case our situation
deteriorated encouraging people to
change their behavior to slow the spread
of the virus and buying crucial time to
get boosters into arms we made the big
call to refocus our national health
service necessarily requiring the
difficult postponement of many other
appointments so that we could double the
speed of the booster program
and thanks to the extraordinary efforts
of our nhs and its volunteers we
delivered the fastest booster program in
europe reaching half our population
before any other european country with
more than 36 million boosters now in
arms across the uk including more than
90
90
of all over 60s in england
and taking a balanced approach we
resisted calls from others to shut down
our country all over again
many nations across europe have endured
further winter lockdowns many have seen
hospitality curfews and nightclubs
closed capacity limits at sports
stadiums the return of social distancing
and in some places christmas and new
year as good as cancelled
but this government took a different
path
we kept england open and we supported
those businesses which faced reduced
demand because of the response to plan b
measures and while we must continue to
remain cautious the data are showing
that time and again this government got
the toughest decisions right
today's latest ons data show clearly
that infection levels are falling in
england and while there are some places
where cases are likely to continue
rising including in primary schools
our scientists believe it is likely that
the omicron wave has now peaked
nationally
there remain of course significant
pressures on the nhs across our country
and especially in the northeast and
northwest
but hospital admissions which were
doubling every nine days just two weeks
ago have now stabilized with admissions
in london even falling and the numbers
in intensive care not only remain low
but are actually also falling
so this morning the cabinet concluded
that because of the extraordinary
booster campaign together with the way
the public have responded to the plan b
measures
we can return to plan a in england and
allow plan b regulations to expire
as a result from the start of thursday
next week mandatory certification will
end
organizations can of course choose to
use the nhs kobe pass voluntarily but we
will end the compulsory use of kovid's
status certification in england
from now on the government is no longer
asking people to work from home
and people should now speak to their
employers about arrangements for
returning to the office and having
looked at the data carefully the cabinet
concluded
that once regulations lapse
the government will no longer mandate
the wearing of face masks
anywhere
mr speaker
mr speaker
[Music]
mr speaker from tomorrow
from tomorrow we will no longer require
face mastering classrooms
and the department for education will
shortly remove national guidance on
their use in communal areas
in the country at large we will continue
to suggest the use of face coverings in
enclosed or crowded spaces particularly
when you come into contact with people
you don't normally meet but
we will trust the judgment of the
british people
and no longer criminalize anyone who
chooses not to wear one
the government will also ease
restrictions further on visits to care
homes and my right honourable friend the
secretary of state for health and social
care will set out plans in the coming
days
mr speaker as we return to plan a the
house will know that some measures still
remain including those on self-isolation
in particular it is still a legal
requirement for those who have tested
positive for covid to self-isolate
on monday we reduce the isolation period
to five full days with two negative
tests and there will soon come a time
when we can remove the legal requirement
to self-isolate altogether just as we
don't place legal obligations on people
to isolate if they have flu
as covid becomes endemic we will need to
replace legal requirements with advice
and guidance urging people with the
virus to be careful and considerate of
others the self-isolation regulations
expire on the 24th of march
at which point i very much expect not to
renew them
indeed
were the data to allow i would like to
seek a vote in this house to bring that
date forwards
in advance of that we will set out our
long-term strategy for living with kobit
19 explaining how we hope and intend to
protect our liberty and avoid
restrictions in future by relying
instead on medical advances especially
the vaccines which have already saved so
many lives
but to make that possible we must all
remain cautious during these last weeks
of winter when there are still over 16
000 people in hospital in england alone
the pandemic is not over and mr speaker
make no mistake
omicron is not a mild disease for
everyone especially if you're not
vaccinated
just look at the numbers in intensive
care in other countries where
vaccination rates are far lower
indeed from our nhs data we know that
around 90 percent of people in intensive
care are not boosted so i urge members
across the house to do everything
possible to encourage any remaining
constituents who have not done so to get
boosted now
and for the next few weeks i encourage
everyone across the country to continue
with the behaviors that we know help to
keep everybody safe washing hands
letting fresh air in getting tested
self-isolating if positive and as i say
thinking about wearing a face covering
in crowded and enclosed settings mr
speaker
omicron tested us
just as alpha and delta did before
but let's remember some of what we've
achieved
we were the first nation
in the world to administer a vaccine
we were the fastest in europe to roll it
out
because outside the european medicines
agency this government made the big call
to pursue our own british procurement
strategy rather than opting back into
the eu scheme as some people urged
we created a world-beating testing
program the largest in europe mr speaker
and procured the most antivirals of any
country in europe too
because this government made the big
call to invest early in lateral flow
tests and in cutting-edge drugs to
protect the most vulnerable
we've delivered the fastest booster
campaign in europe and we are the first
to emerge from the omicron wave because
the government made the big call to
focus on our nhs and to refocus our
activity and lead that campaign to get
boosted now and that's why we've
retained the most open economy and
society anywhere across the european
continent and the fastest growing
economy in the g7 because we made that
tough decision to open up last summer
when others said that we shouldn't and
to keep things open over the winter when
others wanted them shut mr speaker this
week the world health organization said
that while the global situation remains
challenging the united kingdom can start
to see the light at the end of the
tunnel and mr speaker this is no
accident of history
confronted by the nation's biggest
challenge since the second world war and
the worst pandemic since 1918 any
government would get some things wrong
but this government got the big things
right mr speaker and i commend this
statement to the house